bonjour je suis géraldine poulx j'ai
travaillé sur l'histoire du
téléspectateur des années 50 aux années
l'objectif de ma thèse était de répondre
à une question que tout le monde a pu se
poser devant tel ou tel vidéo dina point
fr mais qui pouvait bien regarder ça que
cet instrument
[Musique]
je voulais écrire l'histoire de ce
nouveau personnage qui n'est en même
temps que la télévision le
téléspectateur
monsieur vous êtes téléspectateurs oui
depuis quelle année je suis depuis 1952
pour répondre à cette question j'ai
trouvé à l'inathèque et aux archives
nationales des archives incroyable
permettant de reconstituer l'histoire
des premiers public de la télévision
d'abord il faut savoir que la télévision
elle-même réalise des études sur son
public et ce dès le début à partir de
on a même des mesures d'audience assez
détaillé bonjour madame
j'appartiens centre d'études de sondages
d'opinion et je réalise une petite
enquête pour ce devrait être les visions
d'anhui
mais nous garder quelques instants sa
volontiers et puis il ya les
échantillons du courrier de
téléspectateurs ceux qui écrivent pour
dire qu'il n'ya rien à la télé le
dimanche ou qu'ils n'aiment pas tel
speakerine tout cela pour nous les avons
lu et vous savez que nous faisons grand
corps de doute qu'au lieu que nous
recevons ces archives montrent que les
manières de regarder la télévision ont
considérablement évolué en 40 ans dans
les années 50 on regarde la télévision
essentiellement de manière collective
ôtez les clubs chez un voisin ou au café
ensuite les coups se privatise mais
lorsqu'on vit dans une famille nombreuse
dans les années 60 dans un logement trop
petit lait coûte n'est pas forcément
très attentive la notion de choix est
aussi assez limité à une époque où il
n'y a qu'une ou deux chaînes pas de
magnétoscope et pas de télécommande
on doit avoir ses éléments à l'esprit
quand on tombe sur un programme stupide
les gens qu'ils regardaient n'étaient
pas forcément des abrutis
il n'avait pas un grand choix de loisirs
et d'ailleurs il ne regardait souvent la
télévision que dans l'oeil du choix des
[Musique]
chais pas il ya des trucs qui sont prend
très bien sûr l'une y en a toujours qui
sont d'actions et/ou savez c'est du
panache et vous devriez de savoir que
javier métier parmi les idées reçues il
y en a une qui est très ancienne c'est
l'idée que le public de la télévision
c'est la masse dans les années 70 c'est
vrai certaines émissions ont une
audience considérable certains
feuilletons assemblée chaque semaine
plus de 18 millions de téléspectateurs
c'est un chiffre énorme mais même à ce
moment là les enquêtes sociologiques
montrent qu'il y à des publics les
femmes les agriculteurs les enfants les
cadres les ouvriers chacun avec ses
goûts chacun expert en critique des
programmes jeux peary lacombe et j'aime
mon pays j'aime l'airé du jeu d'un bref
de même que le français moyen n'existe
pas le téléspectateur moyen a toujours
été un mythe
certaines habitudes il est vrai ne
change pas beaucoup vous avez déjà
regardé un programme nul juste pour le
plaisir de vous énerver devant le poste
de télévision
rassurez vous comme votre grand-père
vous êtes un téléspectateur normal sauf
que vos tweets rageur ont remplacé le
courrier des téléspectateurs
[Musique]